oh thank you for coming here
so we had to heal
oh you will
you will not be disappointed you do as
plot it like that it's going to be a
fantastic show and and I have important
news for people who live in this city
reason why you should be happy starting
Monday the LAPD will be wearing body
cameras for the first time very good
news for us being Hollywood the cops
will be like did you get my good side on
that could I do you take that again cuz
I go can I get a pin light and backer me
and I'm not a teenager anymore I could
use a little back daddy
so now that's good news and I would just
say to all my black friends before
leaving the house from now on look in
the mirror sit yourself is this really
the outfit I want to go viral that's
important what
now today's a very important day the
10th anniversary of Hurricane Katrina
and George W Bush went down there today
to New Orleans see I told you he'd make
it eventually also this is important a
craft times the food company recalling 2
million pounds of turkey bacon yeah no
nothing wrong with that just realize
turkey bacon sucks that's know have you
detected what's going on here tonight
I am trying to avoid talking about
Donald Trump that's really what this is
all about so far and yet it's impossible
I mean he's everywhere I never I mean
the media I'd be [ __ ] people CNN
could not be any more obsessed with
Donald Trump if that missing plane
turned up in his hair which is good Oh
his hair his hair they cover a yesterday
Donald Trump brought a woman on stage to
pull his hair to prove that it was real
we had to cover this and by the way it
is real that is his real hair I mean
it's his ass Kerr has hair he brought up
over his head but it is his real hair so
no try I really feel like Donald Trump
is such a perfect example of how people
who are rich and famous can get away
with doing and saying things that other
people would never be able to get away
with it's kind of like the way Michael
Jackson was able to get kids to sleep
over in his bed
you know he's rich and famous choosey
mother's saying now why not you know
whereas you know if Michael and his
monkey we're living in a van I don't
think that would be happening okay but
but Donald Trump what can I tell you
he's pulling away like crazy from the
field of course if you ever met Ted Cruz
you would pull away too but he seems to
be expanding his appeal from hardcore
races to the casual weekend races oh it
got ugly this week did you see in Iowa
with Jorge Ramos I mean oh my god no
Jorge Ramos the the lead anchor on
Univision and he was at this press
conference Donald Trump was giving and
he started to talk and Trump says to him
go back to you in a vision he had him
physically thrown out of the room and of
course Trump's audience is like see he
doesn't have to get rid of Mexicans
so now of course all the Republicans are
scrambling to out Trump Trump with
hating foreigners listen to this
we're expecting a state visit from the
Chinese President Marco Rubio said today
we should downgrade the upcoming Chinese
state visit visit don't treat them he
says to a state dinner yes what a great
mature way to get the Chinese have them
come here and then they have to order
takeout meanwhile on the other side of
the aisle I must say Hillary Clinton's
email problems are only getting worse no
I happen to think this is the biggest
nothing burger scandal non scandal ever
but you know what I got to give it to
the Fox News propaganda machine they do
know how to change opinion the
Quinnipiac poll came out they Ellison to
this they asked voters the first word
that came to their mind when they heard
Hillary Clinton overwhelming that word
was liar second was dishonest third was
untrustworthy other words that came up
crooked criminal deceitful phony [ __ ]
murder and then the pollster said mr.
Biden I really have to make some
and my favorite story of the week Ashley
Madison you're familiar that was the big
story last week the the online dating
site for spouses who want to cheat okay
it got hacked they released all the data
now they've crunched the numbers listen
to this Ashley Madison site the active
users 37 million men 12 thousand women
12 there were 12,000 women for 37
million men so when you see an exhausted
looking housewife in the grocery store
it turns out horny housewives looking
for anonymous stranger sex are like
moderate Republicans they exist only in
theory
you